Writer/Instructor and Script Consultant Shannan
E. Johnson (The Professional Pen): Oh let me
tell you what happened last weekend and you
know that this particular cousin or friend
is just going to talk on and on and on and on
and never get to the point of what happened
Film Courage: What is screenplay structure?
Shannan: Oh very big question right but
I would look at screenplay structure
as how you tell a story and depending
upon the kind of screenplay you're writing
the structure is different in general we've all
learned about three-act structure in some way
shape or form that three-act structure can then be
broken down into just two acts if you're writing
a half-hour multi-camera comedy it can be spread
out into four or five or six acts if you're doing
a one hour drama but your half hour single camera
and your features are usually told in three acts
and if you want to break it down and make it
as simple as possible your first act is your
setup it's giving me all the information I need
to know of why I am here your second act is the
journey to reach the goal and then your third act
is what happened now that I reached the goal right
so it's your resolution so you have your setup
your journey and your resolution and so if you
can understand that any time we hear a story
bedtime story dr seuss what happened last weekend
we're all listening for the setup the journey to
success or failure and then what happened after
that so to me that's like the simplest way of
talking about what structure is for a screenplay
I like how you broke that down because when
we think about let's say a family friend or
a bunch of friends getting together telling a
story about what happened last weekend it makes
sense if they leave out the second act that's but
when we think about a story that we're writing
we could I could see where things would get
convoluted yeah because you also even if you
don't understand story structure you feel it so
you have a cousin or a friend who doesn't know
how to tell stories right so they come in and they
go oh let me tell you what happened last weekend
and you know that this particular cousin or
friend is just gonna talk on and on and on and on
and never get to the point of what happened right
but amongst your friend friend group are amongst
your family they're like no no no let such and
such tell it because you know such and such is
going to give you the setup the journey
and what happened you know the resolution
you know that you're gonna get there you know that
they're gonna give you the details that you need
nothing extraneous or they're gonna say quick
sidebar and then they'll give you this extraneous
stuff and then they'll come back to the story
and keep you following the journey right
so storytelling is storytelling is storytelling
no matter where you're telling it right
in a screenplay it has to be more concise and
it has to be visual but even those people who
don't specifically know they can't give you the
vocabulary they don't have the words to explain
you know how to tell a story we're hearing people
tell stories all the time you know like going back
to that office thing there's somebody in your
office who always stands around the kitchen or
whatever and they have a story you know blah
blah blah and you enjoy their stories then
there's somebody else who always has a story and
you're trying to sneak away from the conversation
because you know you're going to be here for
the next 15 minutes and have learned absolutely
nothing and so that's kind of how you
know that your screenplay isn't working
because we're 30 pages in and I don't I don't have
any information we're 30 pages in and I don't know
what this screenplay is about we're 30 pages
in and I don't know why I’ve been dropped into
it right I don't know what I'm here to witness
because there's a whole lot of talking and going
around the you know bin and over the river and
through the woods but I still having the slightest
idea what my protagonist is trying to do or
possibly who my protagonist is in the first place
right so sometimes that happens but yeah
storytelling is storytelling so if we start to
allow and it's hard when you're the writer right
when it's on the page because now there's all kind
of pressure and stress and stuff but if we allow
ourselves to step away from it and just look at
it like any kind of story we can ask ourselves
like does it feel like my story is moving forward
or does it feel like people are just kind of
talking around some things you know but that's
why again people like me exist because maybe
you can't see that yourself and I pride myself
on being objective my students tell me all the
time your objective right I even had a student
in one of my classes on the university level who
said can you teach the rest of our teachers how to
be objective in this way because when I read their
stuff I don't make them become a particular kind
of writer I'm able to look at them as individuals
which means they write the way that they write
it's not my job to make them fit into this box
right but a lot of the times you may send your
work out and what you receive back is a whole
lot of opinion about what your writing should be
and you should change this and it should be this
you should have that blah blah and it's like
well that's a great story but that's not my story
that's not the one that I'm trying to tell right
so finding someone else who can objectively
look at your stuff they can help to help you to
understand that your story is kind of going around
in circles and not pushing forward just like when
uncle such and such starts telling a story you
know whether it's a drunken one or not right you
know he's never going to get to the point guys
we can go continue playing our basketball game
right so when you say that you like to
to work with people and and find out the
way they tell a story and who they are
how like how is that because because so
somebody could say well this is just who I am and
I i don't really like to formulate full sentences
and I'm just this is just my style yeah is
that acceptable if it's working okay that's
why you have to be objective because sure we can
say I need full sentences but if it's working
if the fact that they're shortening their
sentences is helping me to feel the tone that
they're setting helping me to feel the urgency
of the story I read a screenplay the other day
and every single line of action was just one
sentence but it made the story simple because
it was about a simple guy doing a simple thing
I didn't need more right but if this were a
more convoluted premise if it were a more dramatic
story where I needed to feel more things etc then
now my note would be I need more right and here is
why but I was able to tell this particular writer
usually I would say I need x y and z but this
is working for you because I also want them to
know the rule right I also want them to know
someone else might read this and say x y z
but it's working for you the same thing is true
with I sometimes have people who instill their
voice too much as a writer and so it's jarring
right now I'm hearing you and it's pulling me
out of the story sometimes that works though same
thing with camera angles right it's a no-no for
writers to infuse camera angles in their
screenplay because it's distracting to the read
I'm into something emotional then here you come
with big capital letters close in I already know
that I'm close because I feel it because I'm
reading the story and now you just ruined it for
me by yelling close in as if the director won't
feel that from the context that you've set up but
then I read somebody else's screenplay and they
didn't use it a lot but the moments that they did
worked it felt right it didn't pull me out so
that's what I mean by you have to be objective
to the story you have to understand what is this
story trying to do what does it feel like what's
its tone what's its writer's voice what is
it intending to do and are they doing that
and if they are then why would I tell them to take
away the things that are making that thing happen
you know so if we took let's say a young
Charles Bukowski in a writing program
and you know there's just one way to do this and
then he's presenting this work that might be you
know might raise some eyebrows but that's who he
was that's his style and and maybe he just didn't
find the right teacher let's say yeah I mean and
you know the thing is not everyone's a teacher
just because you know how to write doesn't
mean you know how to teach people how to write
that's just the truth of it and I think we
take the whole we take the education part of it
not seriously enough right so maybe that is the
case because also teachers are only teaching
what they've been taught depending upon how
much experience you've had in the industry
you may think it has to be this way because
I was taught it has to be this way but if
you're continuing to read screenplays even as
a professional writer you'll see that people
break rules all the time people are doing stuff
all the time people make terrible stuff that
makes it onto tv and onto the big screen
all the time so why would I tell my client
that wouldn't work you can't do that it's just not
true you can do anything you want now I'm going
to tell you what the industry standard looks
like I'm going to tell you what people expect
but do you because maybe it's going to work now
there are some things that you just can't do like
if it's if it's unreadable then it's not going
to work you know what I mean if I can't follow
the story because of whatever risk you're
taking or creative licenses you're taking
then it's just not going to work but if I can
follow the story and I understand the story a
lot of those rules really do fly out of the
window they really do I'm going to teach you
what those rules are but again if it's working
then I'm not going to stop you from doing the
thing that's working think about Aaron Sorkin
and how much dialogue are in his screenplays
we're told all the time you can't have that much
dialogue you can't have that much dialogue think
about Shonda Rhimes and how many monologues she
has in her screenplays and we're told all the time
can't have monologues can't have monologues we're
here are two examples where it's working very well
for these two people so I just don't believe
in the extremes I don't believe in yes this is
gonna work and no that's not gonna work because
Hollywood lives like in that in between space and
I think the reason I can give that information
is because I have the experience to know
and then also because I am a teacher so I am
trying to teach you to fish and not giving
you fish right so I'm always going to give you
the why the how the possibilities the what-ifs
and sometimes that doesn't work for people
because they need to know exactly what it is
but I try to explain to them Hollywood is not one
of those places not black or white it really isn't
it's all that stuff in between so you're trying to
write a story that is well executed that's that's
doing what you intended to do that you're going
to be proud of that represents you as a writer
because all of us are going to look back on
something that we wrote and go oh my god that's
terrible oh I can't believe I wrote that so
you're gonna grow from it anyway so you just
have to get to a place where you're happy with
it and it represents you so for someone like
Aaron Sorkin or even Quentin Tarantino I'm sure
there were people telling them this is too much
dialogue I'm sure of it but they were able to
get in with whichever way they got in because
I don't know their stories right but however
it is they got in and it worked out for them.
How was this video helpful to you?